but they're engaged but I think that the
Warriors are playing with tremendous
covenants and I I was going to use
Kenny's point the reason Jordan Pooh
struggles he take divorce shots but when
he's wide open he can be a good player
you cannot survive an NBA on making
tough shots now you can make some of
them but you're going to go on slumps
all the times he reminds me of J.R Smith
who was a good player and they said well
he's streaky the reason he was streaky
he would make those tough bad shots and
then one like a month two weeks later
he'd hit a bunch of Jordan Pooh's
exactly the same way on those pictures
Kenny showed when he's in the Rhythm and
take good shots instead of that thing
where he goes goes steps back and have a
guy hanging all over him you can't
survive on shots like that I need